charles infirmier libéral est en
première ligne depuis plus de vingt ans
alors que le pays est paralysé par la
pandémie lui n'a pas vu son quotidien
changé à l'exception de ce masque qu'il
porte pour rassurer ses patients on
garde une distance quand même avec les
gens on met un masque systématiquement
quand on arrive chez les gens
systématiquement on se lave les mains ou
et où on met du jeune alcoolique
du matin au soir il enchaîne les soins
dans une profession où le contact humain
est primordial
la visite de l'infirmier vital pour
certains si j'avais pas baver
c'est grâce à lui que c'est grâce à lui
et son confrère que j'ai un problème
vient d'apprendre à des finales dont une
chez le stomie d'enfants allaités gétaz
rejoint tous les jours
martigues et des réponses sera votée et
au fil des années charles a créé des
miens avec ses patients et des visites
qui apporte de la chaleur humaine au
quotidien monotone où le temps semble
presque s'être arrêté tous les jours et
me demande comment est ce que j'ai mangé
comme on saura si c'est presque de la
famille mais moi c'est pareil d'ailleurs
j'ai la chance d'avoir beaucoup de
grands mères et beaucoup de grands pères
et que j'aime autant que ma famille
c'est vraiment d'agencés on voit là
certains j'ai les gens ça fait 14 ans
que je les connais que je vais chez eux
matin et soir quoi ça crée des liens
vraiment des liens
jeudi force et voilà j'ai les clés de
chez tout le monde je vois là et c'est
vrai que c'est ce que j'aime dans mon
travail finalement un confinement qui
dure pour limiter la propagation du
virus mais qui creuse un fossé entre les
familles notamment pour les personnes
âgées qui ne peuvent plus recevoir de
visite un isolement qui a des
conséquences sur le bien-être de ses
patients la solitude celle qui vous
ronge de l'intérieur qui vous amenuise à
petit feu celle là on la voit beaucoup
moins elle est beaucoup moins visible
mais je vois là depuis deux trois jours
qu'il ya vraiment une tristesse et une
vraiment quand j'ai une des passions qui
me dit cet après midi j'ai pleuré parce
que je suis toute seule ça me fend le
coeur réellement ça me fend le coeur
parce que là j'ai pas vraiment de
réponses à leur apporter
alors que le pic de l'épidémie n'est pas
encore atteint le matériel arrive au
compte-goutte l'accès aux gangs au
masque reste compliquée pour les
soignants c'est sûr qu'il ya une tension
sur les gants le gnl kaulitz à se
retrouvent et puis les basques
effectivement ça c'est un problème parce
qu'on n'a peut-être pas tout le mal que
l'on aimerait bien avoir depuis le début
de cette crise sanitaire le personnel
médical est totalement mobilisée mais
craint souvent de servir de vecteur à la
maladie vous enchaînez les passions ce
que vous êtes inquiet pour vous est ce
que votre famille est inquiète
howe à la quiétude que j' avais
effectivement d'être malade non pas pour
moi mais pour mes passions
on va pas être un vecteur on intérêt ce
pourquoi ils me demandent de venir c'est
pour leur apporter du bien et pas du mal
malgré un climat anxiogène charles reste
positif
animé par la passion de venir en aide
aux autres coûte que coûte
mon travail c'est de soigner les gens
voilà en se protégeant certes en les
protégeant sur tout mais c'est mon
travail
voilà j'étais militaire avant j'aurais
pu donner ma vie pour mon pays c'était
mon travail aussi je l'accepté ou alors
faut pas le faire je comptabilise près
de 700000 infirmiers sur l'ensemble de
la france dont 60 % de salariés en
milieu hospitalier pandémie ou non
charles continue d'être à l'écouté au
petit soin pour ces patients